every city in the country every city in
the world probably has a pizza place
usually pretty good it's usually pretty
cheap but there's something about making
your own at home that just really drives
the point home do you know anyone that
doesn't like pizza i don't want to know
that person
honestly mickey pizza only takes a few
simple ingredients what you're going to
need is a little bit of warm water it's
going to activate a good amount of dried
yeast a bit of sugar that's going to act
as food for the yeast salt for flavor
flour for the base of the dough
extra virgin olive oil that's going to
one make your dough a little bit easier
to work with it's also going to add just
a little hint of flavor
all right so first things first we have
to bloom our yeast so in warm water and
by warm i just mean like when you put
your finger in it shouldn't feel like
anything it's not cold or hot you're
gonna give it a stir make sure
everything's well hydrated and then
you're gonna see that your yeast is
gonna start to produce a little bit of
bubbles and just means that it's kind of
alive
if you don't see any change that means
that your yeast might be a little on the
old side throw that out and start again
with some fresh yeast we're going to add
salt to the flour and not to the yeast
water mixture salt will slow down the
production of yeast so we want to make
sure that we're adding that later on
once the yeast is already activated
we're going to add extra virgin olive
oil again it's going to add a little bit
of flavor we're going to throw in the
water and sugar mixture
it's easiest in a bowl because it won't
like make a huge mess while you bring
the dough together what we're trying to
do is just hydrate as much as a flour as
we can
once we're happy that we're not gonna
have like water or flour all over the
place we can toss it onto our board and
start kneading it
so kneading is one of those things like
people tend to not do enough set a timer
and do it for 10 minutes you want to be
able to look at it and it's like so
pokey and smooth and fun and what you're
trying to do is just roll the dough on
top of itself and then push forward
you're not trying to tear the dough
you're really just trying to like rotate
and make sure that you're getting like
all parts of the dough incorporated at
the end of it we want like a really nice
pretty top you'll know when you're done
kneading the dough when you press the
dough and it springs back right away so
now what we want to do is get like the
really gorgeous top part of the dough
you can just pull the sides of the dough
from the outside in so that it makes a
nice ball on the other side once you
turn it over push your pinkies in and
kind of rotate the dough into like a
really beautiful round ball
all right cool so ready to rise and
we're gonna go into a big bowl uh put a
little bit of oil in there so that the
dough doesn't stick and then you're
gonna cover the dough itself and oil as
well this is gonna rise significantly we
don't want to stick to the cling film so
i like to cover with cling so that it's
much easier to get off like i've done a
lot of doughs where you cover with a
towel and then it gets stuck to the
towel so i prefer cling
so you can let this rise for an hour if
you don't have a ton of time even better
would be to let this rise overnight so
the one on the left is one that's been
risen for 24 hours and the one on the
right has been rising for an hour it's
still going to be a great flavor it's
still going to be a great texture so the
longer you let this process go just like
the more flavor and the more complexity
is gonna be in your dough
and what we're gonna do now is just
bring this dough back to life so a lot
of work has happened with all this yeast
and it's been a little bit uneven in the
way that it's grown and that's just like
a totally normal process so we're gonna
turn it out and we're gonna knead it
again for another minute or two nothing
different about this process again we're
just evening out the bubbles that are
inside the dough we're gonna do that
shaping thing again so use your pinkies
if you will to kind of push make into a
cute ball
and if you're using strawbot pizza dough
you want to do this as well so knead it
for a minute or two and leave it out at
room temperature while you're doing all
of your other pizza prep and then we're
gonna cut it so as you can see now that
we've cut into this you can look at that
cool pro i just love that it's so cool
okay sorry back to the back to what
we're talking about so you can see like
just how much gluten development just
how much fermentation and you know
growth and all the yeastiness sciency
stuff is going on uh how alive our dough
is like that's an awesome process to see
so we're gonna this is a huge amount of
dough it should make about four good
sized pizzas you can give one to each
person at your party each person in your
family you can shape them you can freeze
half of them or freeze three of them so
you have some for later it's really up
to you
add a little bit more flour
cover it with a towel and let it rise
for one more hour one thing that you
want to recreate from a pizzeria in your
own home kitchen is getting your oven as
hot as it possibly can one thing that's
going to help that is having something
in the oven already preheating that's
going to give you really good bottom
heat so you could do a baking sheet
turned upside down you could do a cast
iron which is really great at holding
heat and the third option if you are
going to be making like a lot of bread
or pizzas at home is to get a pizza
stone and that really holds a lot of
heat as well and it's like a nice open
surface
so let's talk sauce there's a lot of
different options out there and people
like never really know which ones to get
so there's puree and that's going to be
like the finest of all the tomatoes then
there's going to be crushed that might
have a little bit of chunk left in it
diced is going to be diced so it's just
cut up already it's in its sauce and
it's water and then there's whole
tomatoes and so those are the most
intact and those are the ones that i
recommend you can crush them with your
hands or as we're going to do here we're
just going to use an immersion blender
a little safety psa if you have any
leftover sauce do not store it in the
tin can store in a separate container
and make sure to throw the can away
[Music]
now let's talk cheese the thing about
pre-shredded cheese is it has some
product on it that prevents it from
clumping in the bag it just kind of
doesn't allow things to melt as easily
if you shred the cheese yourself it's
going to be much softer it's going to be
a better flavor in the end so if you
have the option we do recommend that you
shred the cheese yourself
one thing about using fresh mozzarella
is that you can leave the chunks as big
as you want so if you're super cheesy
you can have huge chunks on your pizza
so now that our dough is rested it's
ready to be shaped there's a lot of
different ways you can get your dough
out to a good shape what i like to do is
kind of do my like a finger poke if you
will all over the dough one because it's
so fun but also if you can see these
kind of bubbles that are developing i'm
allowing those to stay in the dough and
those are gonna help give you those
awesome pizza bubbles you can stretch
the dough with your hands just kind of
being really careful
you can use your fingers and kind of
spread it if you will do a combo of
things i used to work at a pizza place
and the guy would actually put the dough
like on the side of the table and kind
of stretch it that way and he would let
gravity work its magic and kind of let
the dough stretch out itself it was kind
of fun i thought it was like a cool
technique he was able to do it much
quicker and smoother than i'm able to do
and then the classic way that everyone
wants to know how to learn is the like
tossing of the dough technique so you
kind of want to create a spinning motion
with your knuckles as you're throwing it
in the air so on your knuckles rotate
and toss catch don't don't
so now it's time to assemble our pizza
so we're going to use a turned over
baking sheet so this is going to act as
our peel and a peel is that cool plank
that they have at a pizzeria that helps
get the pizzas in and out of the oven
and we're going to use a little bit of
semolina if you don't have that you can
use flour but we just need something
that the pizza won't stick to the bottom
but also so that it helps us like move
the pizza really quickly off our quote
unquote peel and onto the preheated
baking sheet and then we're going to
just reshape our pizza ever so slightly
re-stretch it out just a little bit so
when you're adding like sauce and stuff
to your dough
just try and work quickly here so like
don't panic or anything but if you are
too slow it's going to be much harder to
get the pizza off the peel and into the
oven so we're going to use the zabala
mozzarella and i like to tear it up
pretty pretty small so that we can get
like a really good even amount of cheese
throughout the whole thing
so you want to take it off when the
cheese is a nice dark deep brown and the
crust is like a golden brown as well and
then we like to do a little bit of fresh
basil on top again i'm kind of a perfect
biter so i like everything to be like a
good bite size i don't want to like bite
into a huge piece of basil and then like
have it hang out of your mouth you know
what i mean like
yum so that's like a classic margarita
look at the crunch yes all right cool
and now you eat really easy
and a little like pizza bianca if you
will or like a white pizza or a pizza
without a sauce that's just going to be
a little bit of olive oil
again more cheese of your choice we're
using mozzarella we put a bit of dried
oregano on top of this as well and this
is going to go into the oven as is
[Music]
yeah this is like a super easy one at
the end of the cooking process we
actually added some fresh ricotta uh
which is like a really nice fresh cool
bite this is a great summertime option i
feel like um and then even on top of
that a little bit of fresh pesto that we
had so this is like a really gorgeous
light fresh pizza it looks like
luxurious right there's something about
it it's just very like
i don't know it's like kid friendly but
it's also
like bougie friendly
and then obviously the other fan
favorite is a good classic pepperoni so
with that it's just cheese sauce spicy
pepperoni you can grate some fresh
parmesan on top at the end of it none of
that weird stuff in the canister you
gotta freshly grate it so much better
yeah and the cool thing about pizza is
whatever you want my favorite toppings
seriously i'm not even kidding are like
bacon
and olive
it's like so salty and crunchy it's so
good i love it
[Music]
you